what's the nature of the objection mr
belunkus
he's testifying he's talking about
with regards to uh
mr morris it's clearly hearsay
and i'm not sure
yeah that normal let's see if mr jones
can explain it
judge george morris was given a lifetime
ban that was the nature of the next
question was giving a lifetime ban by
safe sport on august 5th 2019 which
obviously is just two short days before
the
shooting
um
as
what was the ban for
i do not intend to elicit that judge for
prejudicial reasons but it was for
sexual misconduct
i think it certainly is relevant but i
was not intending to elicit that again
because uh
on balance
i recognize that that could be
prejudicial
i don't see the relevance of someone
else being born well if it's mr
barrissone's
what's the relationship between mr
barristone and
this individual mr morris mr morris is
essentially one of his mentors and
someone that he looked up to as a a a
leader in a paradigm of horsemanship in
the community
his entire career to the point where he
would go and watch mr morris
coaching and training even though they
were in different disciplines so that he
could learn
how to be a better coach and trainer
obviously the fact that that person who
he looked up to
so closely was given a lifetime ban from
the sport two days before
with all the other testimony that we've
heard
well is there is there information that
mr barroso
knew about that lifetime ban prior to
august 7th at the time it was handed
down on the 5th or 6th he did he spoke
to him judge he spoke to him on august
5th 2019. so he spoke to him the scene
how do you know that
uh
ms ms gray
talked to him about that
and the defendant told that to
her as well as having i believe those
conversations with mr harden
judge
if i may
what the prosecutor is going to try to
do when i have a
transcript of an interview with mr
morris is that my client
called him i believe on the fifth
and basically after hearing about the
band
according to mr morris
said that michael expressed his
condolences
said he was sorry
um the investigator for the prosecutor's
office then starts questioning mr morris
with regards to his ban
mr morris is telling the investigator
not michael barason
that safe sport is being used as a
weapon
you know
people have killed themselves over it
you know it's a horrible uh you know
a body
and basically
he says to the investigator it ruined my
life and then the investigator
interjects to mr morris not mr barrisson
well do you know that lauren cataract
was going to turn michael barrison into
save sport and mr morris says that i
quote words to the effect
that would have destroyed his life
there is nothing to indicate that that
statement was ever made to michael
barason there's nothing to indicate that
they talked about that all the
prosecutor has is a transcript of their
conversation with mr morris where he
renders an opinion in his mind after
going through what he did which
again was a horrific story as to what
effect that would have on michael
barrasso
and i don't see i don't see how they get
that in to be honest with him i'm not
going there josh no i don't think he's
going there he's going in
i suppose he's going in you want to get
in the fact that
a mentor of mr barristones was banned
for life from the sport he left
two days before the shooting two days
before the shooting isn't that relevant
to mr barroson's state of mind no
what problem is that someone else being
a band and then dcp and p shows up at
his house
you don't think that's relevant that his
mentor two days before got a lifetime
ban for sexual misconduct and then dcp
and p shows up
well
everything else you say goes to a state
of mind why shouldn't this if it's a
stressor everything else has been
rejected
basically no it's not
just your manner of trying to get it in
has been rejected
and it's hearsay judge how's he going to
get any of this in
which witness has the personal
first-hand knowledge of this ban
well the defendant i suppose do you have
information that the the defendant had
conversations with this witness
he could elicit it from as a defendant
statement if he knew about the ban he
has a phone record that he called them
that's it no taped conversation no email
no text message well you just said that
there was an expression of condolence on
the part of mr barrison basically that's
what mr morris said judge
not mr barrison
how do you how do you get this in that
the defendant
judge i believe you knew about knew
about the the lifetime ban i believe the
testimony from ms gray which wasn't
objected to when she testified
was that this was explosive news in the
equestrian community when it happened i
would have to go back to my notes to
look at that but she said it was
something that everyone was talking
about
my recollection is that she said that
she test she discussed it with the
defendant
and that the defendant knew who judge
morris wasn't knew about that
again my recollection or my anticipation
rather is that mr harden will testify to
that
i
again can can recall ms gray and show
her the text message where she sends the
text message that says
michael to justin mr harden michael just
talked to george
on august 5th 2019. so i don't want to
leave the court to believe that i'm
speculating about whether they had these
conversations
but that would be your say too how do we
how do we know what was said
but it's it's again i'm not trying to
bring in all of the particulars or the
specifics i have no intent
i think i have a good faith argument to
argue as your honor just said that
individual was was given a lifetime ban
for sexual assault
the defendant jumps to a conclusion when
dc pnp shows up there that warren
canorack has called dcpmp on him and
reported him for sexual assault and five
minutes later or ten minutes later he's
trying to kill her
that
obviously goes to his state of mind his
motivation
so it's not hearsay it goes to show
directly the effect that it had on him
he finds that out and the moment dcp
gets on scene he's going to load a gun
get a gun and kill somebody
toronto he objected to the question as
to what dc cnp said i know but so well
is it dcp worker going to testify i
anticipate she's going to testify
and i anticipate she's not going to
testify that she was not there to
investigate a report of sexual assault
again the defendant jumped to that
conclusion
because of this report to about george
morris it was all over every equestrian
website newspaper
it was on
all kinds of news outlets
so if his friend killed somebody judge
mr belinkas
you put in the defendant's state of mind
correct you put that in
are you saying that learning that your
mentor was banned from the sport of or
the equestrian activities
had no effect on mr barrison or didn't
have not even that didn't have the
potential to affect his fragile state of
mind at that time no i don't i don't
think so judge there's nothing that he
never indicated that to anyone to any of
the doctors the state's doctors the
defense doctors you know that wasn't
that that doesn't mean it's not relevant
because it didn't indicate it to a
doctor
there may be other things that doctors
can be cross-examined on things did he
know about this did you know about this
what did he what did he know judge
that he was
that he was bad
what are the circumstances
well it's a lifetime ban two days before
i i think it
it arguably goes to his state of mind
his mental state at that time
now i'm not sure whether getting into
the specifics of it especially because
of all the information so far about miss
cataract notifying safe sport
and ms gray and mr barrisson contacting
safe sport
and sending
759 pages
in august to save sport
well that's part of the case
and if mr barry's own state of mind is
an issue here
whether it affects this state of mind i
don't know whether
i had no idea but
i think it's
an event of some
notoriety that your mentor is banned for
life from the sport
and here comes dcp and p
confronting them
that may certainly impact
how mr barrisone reacted
maybe he saw him going the same way the
state will argue maybe he believed he
was going to be banned now because of
safe sports involved like his mentor and
and ruin his life
investigations that literally take years
the allegations with mr morris
had to do with an allegation of 50 years
prior to that it's completely different
it's not has nothing to do with the
investigation
it's this defendant learning about it
[Music]
it's this defendant
he learned about it
miss gray said that
mr this witness is going to say the same
thing that he that he learned about it
and i'm also conceding that i'm not
going to get into the particulars of
that because i think that would require
getting into what specifically did the
defendant know versus did it what i
think is indisputable from all of the
evidence and from the witnesses is that
the defendant knew about the suspension
knew about the lifetime ban
that's the fact that i intend to elicit
not the circumstances underlying and
again judge you excluded me getting from
mary haskins grade the fact that a
complaint to safe ward was in fact filed
against her and she was exonerated
and again we're not getting into the
result but but this is
but mr mr mr belinkus
the reason why i banned that is because
the result as it pertained to ms gray
has absolutely zero relevance
to this defendant's state of mind how
about when when he's told about mr
morris getting a lifetime ban and then
he sees miss gray which basically judge
were the exact same allegations he was
included in that complaint to safe sport
so she's cleared he should have
absolutely no concern about any
complaint being filed against
i don't i don't know i don't know
i don't know what his concern was
again the compliments judge you wouldn't
let me get into what the complaint was
with mary haskins it was with mary
because you asked it about her state of
mind not his and
no you didn't no no you didn't you
didn't ask that mr balance you didn't
bring that up you're bringing it up now
but you didn't bring it up then
and i and the and the reason why i ruled
it out
was because it pertained
to the ruling against her that's how the
question was asked
and i said it's not relevant whatever
the ruling was about her is not relevant
and i even mentioned
the defendant's state of mind is at
issue and you didn't bring up at that
time that the complaint was about him as
well
because because i didn't think the court
would consider bringing up a lifetime
ban of some someone else that has
nothing to do i submit to this kid i
think it does it's you you are bringing
in the fact the whole issue
and you mentioned before here is the
defendant's state of mind
all right and
the state thinks that this may have
impacted his state of mind and it and it
the jury may think the same thing
and again i understand the courts really
i understand your position that that
that's my ruling it comes in not not the
misconduct not the nature of it but just
the fact that mr barrison learned two
days before this incident
that his mentor received a lifetime ban
from safe sport
and again now
that you've moved this way
i'm asking the courts to allow me to ask
miss gray what the results were with
regards to the complaint against her
from safe sport
the exact same complaint was made
against michael barrisson and i submit
if one is
who made those complaints lauren
cataract judge
again if you want to call her in your
case you can call her
after the shooting
this was at some point after the
shooting would not have affected what
was the safe sport ruling
then it doesn't have reality it doesn't
then my whole issue was is as it
pertains to the defended state of mind
at the time of the shooting not what
happened after the fact the judge so you
know the complaint was made before the
shooting the results but we're talking
about the results
what relevance is it if it came in a day
after or a month after or two months
after it couldn't have affected the
defendant's state of mind because the
incident already happened
i mean that that's
abundantly clear so we'll let it in
let's bring um
all right i'm going to take a quick
break and then um we'll address that
issue that i brought up
um